of course optimizing the number of bytes
transferred is important you may expect
that optimizing network usage just means
minimizing the number of bytes
transferred things like don't send a
multi-megabyte image to a phone when
it's only going to be rendered at a
small pixel size
that's certainly part of it but there's
other things at play too and in the end
all of these things are important
how often we send requests needs to be
optimized for the latency of the
particular cellular network and we have
to be careful about the power
consumption as well
although it's less important now we do
still need to optimize for the maximum
number of allowed tcp connections